foreign
[Music]
let's do this thing
we're 1874 folks it's crazy how fast
these these speedruns end up going but
but I think this is the most interesting
part of the speedrun for a lot of people
because almost all of the games are now
very competitive we're still winning a
couple quickly but most of the games
including the last one if you want to
watch a really good speeder in game I
published the VOD on yesterday's stream
and it was or stream day before
yesterday I didn't stream yesterday and
it was super interesting like it was a
game full of tactical details and all
sorts of cool stuff
all right but for now
let's continue we'll probably get black
and we will 1988.
okay good a year
and we will get another
Sicilian hopefully we get an accelerated
Dragon no so of course
as we've established below 1500 or so
almost nobody plays the open Sicilian
and at this level I would say it's about
50 50 between people who play the open
Sicilian by which uh we refer to Knight
F3 and D4 that's the main line Knight C3
is the entry point it's the gateway to a
bunch of different anti-sicilians there
is no one name for Knight C3 it's just a
developing move but it's the entry point
for the close Sicilian and the Grand
Prix attack which is F4 in the next move
there is also a very popular line that
goes Bishop to B5 this is the
recommendation in a lot of books that
Advocate
anti-sicilians and the caveat that I'll
share and not the caveat the disclaimer
that I should share is that me
personally as a knight of player in real
life I play the move D6 here and I've
already explained the rationale behind
choosing between D6 E6 and Knight C6
which are all totally viable
continuations which which of them you
choose depends on which Sicilian you
play against Knight F3 and D4 because
white could conceivably play Knight F3
on the next move and move order you into
a sicilian that you don't play that's
why we play Knight C6 because
for for the purposes of the speed run
were accelerated Dragon players so if
white plays Knight F3 in this position
we want to be able to play G6 and
transpose into the accelerator okay
that's a lot of blah blah blah let's
focus on Bishop B5
so the move here that is considered very
standard is Knight C6 to D4 much like in
the trumpowski on the other flank you
play Knight F6 to E4
but that's not the only move right you
can still play G6 you can still play E6
and I would like to avoid Theory
in this game so we're gonna play an
alternative that is not very common
which is the immediate G6 we're
basically going to play The Accelerated
Dragon structure The Accelerated Dragon
moves against the slightly different
closed Sicilian
we're gonna go G6 and the reason that
this move isn't considered the best is
because if Bishop takes C6 but if you
think about it right we've already faced
the rosalimo which is essentially the
real Lopez against the Sicilian and in
the rosalimo it's totally standard for
us to allow the move Bishop takes C6
because yes our Pawn structure is
damaged but we also get the bishop pair
and we get a lot of good stuff in return
for uh the sort of visual damage and one
of the other good things that we get if
we take with a B Pawn which is what
we're gonna do we get early access to
the D5 Square we're able to push D5
rather quickly if we want to
so we get the bishop pair we get the B
file and we get pretty decent control of
the center I think that's a pretty good
bargain even though white is considered
to be slightly better according to
Theory like if you turn on the engine
yes white is better here but I've always
found that this is a very good practical
way to avoid to dodge a lot of the
theory of this variation okay so how
should we proceed white is playing the
recommended moves white is grabbing
space on the king side with F4 we
basically have an early choice we can of
course play D5 or we can play uh D6
which is a more modest move and either
way we're going to continue by
developing or not I'd like to show
everybody a really cool setup that I
think is very underrated
and that I think poses serious problems
to why it actually let me think about
whether we want to do that here or not
so I'm trying to decide actually between
D6 and D5 here and there is a lot of
positional considerations that I don't
have time to explain right now that I'll
sort of tackle in more depth after the
game
okay let's go D6 let's play this more in
this sort of Sicilian spirit and you
might be wondering okay like what is
possibly the downside of pushing D5
isn't that just clearly the better move
because it controls more of the center
not quite D5 has some serious drawbacks
one of which is that white can push E5
and blunt our Bishop and the C5 Pawn
could become a serious Target as a
result right now that pawn is nicely
protected by its neighbor on D6 so I
think most people's instincts here is of
course to play Knight F6 and to Castle
but as I've already talked about in a
previous speedrun game this setup which
is the Grand Prix attack setup is
incredibly dangerous and one of White's
ideas is to push the f-bond to F5 and
later to trade dark squared Bishops at
Bishop H6 I'll remind you of how bad
things can go for black if you're not
careful in this position but there is an
idea that was taught to me many many
years ago by my coach and this is not a
well-known idea
I'll show you how this is applied in the
closed Sicilian and I had some games
where I applied this idea with a lot of
success and it's the move Knight to H6
which already should get your weird
senses going like what on Earth are we
doing on H6 where are we going
and you might say oh I get it we're
going to G4 no we're not because the
moment the Knight hits G4 it's chased
back by the h-bond So What on earth is
the point of heading to G4 instead we're
preparing something
and this something is a way to contest
the king side to prevent white from
carrying out his main King side plan
which always involves the move F5 if
white doesn't get F5 in then White's
dark Square Bishop is left without a
clear home you might also know that
after White Castles short this queen
from D1 usually migrates over to H4
where it applies serious pressure on
black sitting side so it's very easy to
get checkmated in this type of position
what is it that we're preparing we're
preparing the move F5 we're preparing F7
F5
by which we freeze the pawn on F4 we can
test some of the center and we create
tension in the center that
draws White's attention away from the
King side and toward the part of the
board where black is a superiority I
think our opponent doesn't really know
what we're preparing H3 is a clear sign
that he was expecting us to go to G4 so
that's kind of a Tempo loss and we
shouldn't dilly dally we should play F5
immediately we don't want to allow white
to expand on the king side with G4 our
Knight could actually get trapped as a
result so definitely we want to strike
with F5 right away
and the other thing that I like about
this approach is that we're facing our
opponent with a set of challenges that
he's likely to be unfamiliar with like
most people when they study these types
of structures from the white side they
kind of take for granted that the Knight
is developed to F6 so at higher levels
it's actually a great idea to analyze
Sidelines not necessarily on the first
or second move but to find Sidelines
within more popular openings because
your opponent is just less likely to
know the theory and also less likely to
know the typical idea so your opponent
is going to be on their own uh sooner
rather than later which is always a good
thing as my coach would say make them
use their own brain not stockfish's
brain
again no question in my mind that
objectively black is worse here let me
not embellish the situation I think
white has a slight but stable Advantage
but in order to assert this advantage
and Carry It Forward white will have to
be very accurate white will have to
successfully solve the problem of the
central tension
and in particular what I mean is that
white will have to choose the right time
to push the pawn down to E5 taking on F5
is a terrible idea for white because it
well it relinquishes White's control of
the center it allows the knight from H6
to jump into the action via F5 and later
D4 and in general it just releases the
tension to Black's favor we also have
the bishop pair so if the position opens
up then our light squared Bishop is
going to be really really happy but if
white plays E5 prematurely
what could happen is that E5 Pawn itself
becomes a serious weakness so there's a
lot of positional and tactical
subtleties that are at play here and I'm
going to try to demonstrate some of them
during and after the game okay Queen E2
so how should we proceed well there's
really no doubt in my mind that we need
to safeguard our King so let's Castle
kingside as a non-committal move which
we know we have to play at some point
so let's play it now
and there is a tactical trick that so
many players Miss which is
uh a a typical property of this Knight
H6 F5 line it starts with E5 we respond
by tucking our Knight away on F7 and in
that position castle and King side
blunders yeah it blunders upon
and that's a very hard tactic to see if
you're not already aware that it exists
so we'll see what our opponent comes up
with her we also could have played yeah
we could have played E7 E5 and created
the pawn box but with a king still in
the center that's way premature
especially with the Queen x-raying the
king we don't want to open up the center
just yet now I would seriously consider
the move E5 on the next move although it
is very very risky because if you think
about it once the pawns are traded we
are reopening lights dark squared bishop
and we're seriously weakening the double
pawns on the queen side
so the fact that our opponent is
devoting a lot of time is is a clear
sign that he's sort of on his own
okay so again
the position is relatively closed which
means that there are more than one
options more than one decent move in
every position but uh in every one of
these positions on the next few moves
but I'd like to continue in the spirit
of this setup so there's one more
improving move that we should always
make we've got a knight on H6 what was
the purpose of putting it there well it
was to prepare F5 but now that we've
played F5 it's time to find the Knight a
better and more permanent home while
there aren't that many houses for sale
the real estate market is crazy the only
square is F7 let's bring it back to F7
you might look at this and say well I
don't get how this move how the Knight
on F7 is better than on H6 well first of
all night's on the rim or Grim on H6 it
was really controlling nothing at least
now it's controlling some squares in the
center on the king side but the main
appeal of this move will be revealed if
white plays E5 E5 is a tactical blunder
here I'm hoping our opponent plays it so
I can demonstrate this idea but you know
a 2000 player probably should
see this concept and see through it
now of course also on F7 the Knight is
preparing uh potential Pawn push uh e75.
Bishop D2 okay so moot point put it
aside Bishop D2 by our opponent I'm
assuming that he's preparing Rook a to
E1 and then he's going to consider
pushing E5 we're still not afraid of he
takes F5 we can just recapture with the
bishop that's not a problem
okay so let's think about this for a
moment
what options are available to us well we
could toss in the move Rook B8 one thing
that we could do
totally risk-free and it's not gonna
hurt us we know that is just to play the
move Rook being and you want to be
comfortable oh actually I had a good
move Queen B6 also I just realized that
although Queen B6 would have run into
Knight A4 I was thinking about Queen B6
and then pushing the C Pawn with a
discovered check right because any time
your opponent pushes their F Pawn and
Castle's King said you should always be
aware of what's happening on this
diagonal so I'm making a mental note to
myself to constantly look for Bishop D
Ford Shack and maybe Queen B6 and C4 uh
because that could become important
later in the game in fact the reason
that E5 is a tactical blunder has to do
directly with the fact that the A7 G1
diagonal is exposed
so a lot of people are suggesting Bishop
to A6 now Bishop A6 was a very
reasonable move what worries me after
Bishop A6 is actually e takes F5 because
just a couple of moves ago we had four
Defenders on this pawn and E takes F5
didn't seem like a problem it's still
not a problem here but it becomes a
problem if you move your Bishop away
from C8 because I really don't want to
take back with the pawn sneaking back
with a pawn creates massive strain on
our King side white could start
harassing that pawn with Knight H4 even
Queen to E6 could be a possible move if
the bishop moves away from C8
so for the time being let's keep our
Bishop on C8 I really like moves like
Rook B8 because there there's a low
price tag right you know that this move
is not going to harm your position
but the reward is pretty immense we've
just forced white to spend two minutes
and make a rather weakening move now the
Knight on C3 is really soft and that
could help us in certain situations if
the position opens up we never know when
something like that could come in handy
so I think some of you might be tempted
by Queen to A5
but if you look at that move carefully
it walks into an x-ray and white could
even move like a knight A4 attacking the
queen
and then the Rook could move into E1 and
we want our Queen participating in the
action I'm anticipating that the center
is gonna open up at some point so we
want to keep our Queen in the vicinity
of the center
I actually have to think here for a
couple of moments
so I'm going to think in silence
yeah and I mean I'm not bsing this
really is a very complicated position
people watching and you should be like
this is lame he has to think okay I
think it's time to play E5
I think this is as good
as any of a moment to strike with E5
so again what is the this might seem
ridiculously complicated to in fact it's
not hard to calculate that black doesn't
lose any material here because both of
our pawns that form the pawn box are
extremely well defended right if white
plays F takes E5 we take back with a
knight now from a bird's eye positional
standpoint the reason that we're trying
to open up the center is because we have
the bishop pair and it's also because
White's King is a little bit weak right
White's already pushed the F Pawn I
guess we've done the same but when you
have a fan cattle Bishop that lends a
lot of support to your king white
doesn't have that equivalent so if you
think about it let's say white plays
Effie which he just did of course we
don't want to take back with a pawn here
and weaken the doubled pawns and blunt
our own Bishop we take back
automatically with the Knight let's say
that white plays Knight takes E5 we take
back with the bishop well hopefully you
can notice that the bishop is aiming at
the H2 square and our Queen is only two
steps away from combining with the
bishop to form a battery and form
Unstoppable mate threads
okay so broadly speaking the side of the
bishop pair benefits if the position
opens up uh because it makes it easier
to exploit uh uncontested squares that
your Bishop's control
uh and the second Factor actually is
this loose Knight on C3 which could be
targeted in a lot of lines White's
Bishop right now is tied down to its
protection which is creating further
strain on White's position Rook ae1 is a
great move by our opponent but I think
it gives us an opportunity to do
something really really productive we
could continue expanding on the king
side and basically set up a potential
Pawn storm that could be supported by
our light script bishop and our dark
Square Bishop right now our light scored
Bishop is kind of butt hurt because it's
staring at its own Pawn so you might say
well then let's take on e4 but I don't
want to take on e4 because that would
allow White's Knight to jump into the
center even though broadly speaking we
want to open up the center we don't want
to do it at the cost of allowing White's
pieces to get really active
and you might well what what is
dangerous about the Knight on e4 well
it's the fact that first of all when
it's on C3 the Knight is vulnerable as
we've already established if it lands on
e4 it's putting a lot of pressure on our
weak Pawns in the center and hopefully
you can see that that's really not the
way to go instead of playing F takes E4
I want to play the move F4
and again it might seem like I'm
constantly contradicting myself I just
said we want to open up the center now
suddenly we're keeping it closed you
know what are we doing well we're not
really keeping the center closed right
F4 is a move on the king side the center
is still open enough for us to be able
to benefit from it if you look at these
squares on E5 and D4 our Bishop is
already controlling those squares our
Pawn is controlling an important Square
on D4 so what is it what does F4
accomplish well a couple of things it's
blunting White's dark squared Bishop
even further
and this Pawn is not at any risk of
getting captured 95 Bishop E5 and we
have enough Defenders and even if we
didn't white could not leave it's a
babysitting of the C3 Knight and worse
comes to worst we could support the pawn
with G7 uh G6 G5 and G5 is a move that
we might actually play voluntarily as
part of a pawn storm that I just
mentioned consider what would happen if
we play G5 H5 and then G4 that's only
three moves and those pawns on F4 and G4
are going to be incredibly menacing if
you're a king's Indian player you should
be a you should sort of subconsciously
and intuitively appreciate the power of
a pawn storm like that
so we're only three moves away from
carrying that out and putting that into
effect and this Pawn produces a cramping
effect on White's pieces all of them are
now sort of just you know lazily staring
at the pawn white is suffering from a
lack of space I feel like I said that
unintentionally with a New York accent
when your opponent takes a prolonged
think like this and already white is
down to six and a half minutes it's a
good idea to generate a list of helpful
moves that you could play unless your
opponent does something super committal
or something that forces you to react 91
is a great move I actually was going to
point out that this is the best move
what is the idea of Knight T1 well our
opponent moves the Knight away from a
vulnerable square and my guess is that
he wants to put a bishop on C3 rather
than a knight in order to contest uh the
bishop on G7 but what you should notice
is that even if our opponent plays
Bishop C3 that does not create any
threats yes then if white takes on E5
we're gonna have to recapture with the
pawn and we've already discussed that
that comes with a significant price tag
but our main goal now has shifted from
the center to the king side where we're
trying to put into effect this Pawn
storm with G5 and H5 and G4 so it may be
worth paying the price of blunting our
Bishop in order to make that happen
so I don't see any reason that we should
not initiate our attack with G5 we could
also improve our position with a move
like Queen to E7 for example right or
maybe even Bishop to E6 so largely we
have a choice between getting down a
business and rolling up our sleeves and
making a couple more Preparatory moves
and I will tell you I'm not sure that G5
is best maybe bishop E6 or just a calm
developing move is what the computer
would prefer like one more of those
moves would make the Attack stronger but
I would also argue that G5 isn't such a
committal move it's not like we play G5
and then we can't go back and play
Bishop E6 yeah the pawn is a little bit
of a weakness and White's pressuring it
but in an emergency we could even play
H6 and build up a punch in so this is I
think what's important when you're
initiating an attack it's to make the
least committal moves first if possible
of course and uh when you make the least
committal move first you maintain the
flexibility to change your approach if
your opponent does something unexpected
or something that you missed or you
realize suddenly wait a second you know
the attack is not as strong as I thought
it was going to be you can double back
and start making improving moves instead
Knight F2 so clearly our opponent is
respecting the threat of G4 the upside
for us of this move is that Bishop C3 is
no longer a possibility because then we
play Knight takes F3 check and the
bishop has lost its Defender
so a great example of of over
stubbornness would be H5 H5 would be a
blunder because after 95 white will be
able to take that pawn
but we also should not play actually
Queen E8 is interesting
but that blunders the pawn on G5 also
not appetizing so I actually think that
this is a great time
for us to make a slower move for us to
make a preparatory move that that Shores
up our pieces and solidifies our
position and gives our other pieces more
flexibility I like the move H6 here
because I am annoyed that our Queen is
not able to get to G6 I think if the
queen got to G6 that would be a great
Square for the queen because it would be
preparing G4 and it's just a nice safe
Square that's out of the way of the
other pieces
there is a reason that I don't want to
play Bishop E6 just yet and it's a very
complicated reason so I'll save the
explanation until after the game
assuming of course that our opponent
doesn't play the move that I think he
might make
but okay the tldr is that in certain
situations if our opponent moves the C
Pawn I wanted to reserve the right to
play Bishop to A6 which is a completely
senseless move otherwise but if the pawn
on D3 has been softened up Bishop A6
should make a lot of sense to you as a
way to put pressure on this newly
weakened Point Knight takes C5
okay so now a big decision
from a positional standpoint there's no
question that we should take with the
Bishop from a tactical standpoint taking
with a pawn actually makes a lot of
sense because what that move does is it
solidifies the F4 Pawn even further and
it will make it a little bit easier for
us to play H5 G4 in the future
so D takes C5 very clear drawback it
weakens the queen side we might end up
losing the C5 Prime but if we want to
Checkmate our opponent then we should
take on E5 with the pawn that's a very
Kings Indian style move
I'm not sure which move we should play
I'll be honest I'm really not sure I my
intuition says Pawn takes C5
but the Capa Blanca inside of me says
Bishop takes E5
the moral of the story is don't trust
capablanca
trust the Mikhail Tal
trust the tall voice inside of you
yeah Cabo Blanca would be cringing
hardcore at this move and it might be a
mistake we might pay the price and lose
but we'll see at least I'll die trying
okay Queen H5 that's a great move
actually
so now our next step is to chase this
queen out of H5 there's no doubt that we
are not going to be able to play H5
unless unless what unless the queen is
chased out of H5 there's only one piece
mathematically capable of chasing the
queen out of H5 and that would be the
Bishop from where can the bishop chase
the queen out of H5 well F7 or E8 Bishop
B6 just seems like a more natural
developing move then Bishop to D7
now don't worry about Knight G4 here
which I think our opponent might be
banking on because it's a move with an
incredibly uh incredibly dangerous
drawback for white which is that the
queen is then trapped and after Knight
G4 we shouldn't Play Bishop to F7
because Knight takes H6 check weasels
out of the situation but the pawn has to
be first defended with King H7 but after
that we'll be threatening Bishop F7 and
then the queen will be trapped white
might just have to move the Knight back
to F2
and it might already be too late
our attack is certainly not gone our
attack hasn't even started yet but once
it starts once the wheels start turning
I can assure you that the attack is
gonna be ridiculously powerful this is
this ability to understand what's going
to happen in the long run right now it
seems lame we haven't played H5 yet
we're not even close to playing H5
actually we are very close to playing H5
if we play Bishop F7 forcing the queen
away guess what we play H5 and the
moment we get this Pawn to G4 I think
those pawns are gonna tear white apart
and you should kind of understand that
intuitively
what I also like about this position is
that if you look at these pawns on the
queen side they produce a very
disgusting visual effect but they're
hard to attack this bishop in order to
attack the C5 Pawn needs to make a two
move maneuver and even if it gets to A3
okay even if it wins The Pawn on C5 is
that pawn Mission critical to our King
side attack it absolutely isn't we could
even afford to lose our entire Queen
side and the attack would carry on and
that's the important thing to understand
about openings that involve an attack on
uh the king side like the king's Indian
that's the clearest uh similarity
similar opening to the position that we
have
you often need to give up an entire
flank or a ton of material on that flank
because you don't have the time to waste
yeah our opponent is really struggling
here to find a move I don't really know
what our opponent should do
it's a very difficult position for white
I think our decision to take on E5 of
the pawn is a really good one H4 okay so
now things get very concrete H4 is an
excellent move by the way I think this
might be the only way for white to stay
alive wow I'm impressed with this move
I saw it out of the corner of my eye but
I underestimated it this is a great move
I don't think it solves White's problems
though for the record
and I think the way to keep posing
problems is extremely counter-intuitive
my intuition is suggesting a
ridiculously counter-intuitive move
what what is the intuitive move well I
would argue well first of all some of
you might be attracted to G4 but after
Knight takes G4 I don't see a clear way
to continue because you have to waste
the tempo on King H7 also the E5 Pawn is
hanging there I don't like it
the counter-intuitive move is G takes H4
and in the interest of time I'm going to
play this move and then I'm going to
explain it
might look into well this defeats the
whole purpose of our entire attack which
was to play G4 but you have to assess
this position
on a separate sort of
separately from the previous position
because yes we don't have the capacity
to play G4 but in return some doors
close other doors open very important to
understand that in the context of
evaluating ideas you can't be dogmatic
and you can't
tell yourself either I carry out this
idea or it's a total failure what am I
talking about I'm talking about the move
Queen to G5 which is a huge threat as a
result why is it a threat because if the
Queens are traded then everything is set
right again and then we will be able to
play G4 and even in the end game these
pawns are going to Massacre white on the
king side not to mention that we are up
a pawn and that cannot be discounted
either we're up upon right I just took a
free Pawn
also the G file is opened and that might
be the more obvious factor to you
the G file can be readily exploited all
we need to do is move our King out of
the way and boom we put a rook on G8
that pawn on G2 is in our crosshairs
so we'd have to bring the king over move
the Rook over and then move the dark
squid Bishop over but because the center
is close three moves isn't such a long
time
but hopefully everybody realizes why
Queen G5 is such a dangerous threat if
white does not trade queens and moves
the queen back to F3 then we're already
aiming down the G file and there we can
optimize the process by lifting our Rook
from F6 to G6 with a huge attack and of
course this H Pawn can be used as a
battering ram we can push it to H3 at
some point and shatter White's only
remaining King protection I think G
takes H4 is almost a no-brainer at a
high level
almost no brain which doesn't mean if
you don't
you know understand the rationale behind
that movie you should feel bad but
hopefully that explanation made sense
that H3 is an excellent move I I have to
commend our opponents finding I think
the only way to stay in the game
now we have a lot of tempting moves here
there's Bishop to F7 obviously the idea
of Knight H3 is to stop Queen G5 we
could take on H3 and play Queen G5 check
and trade Queens but then the position
becomes uncomfortably closed and I think
white white has excellent drawing
chances in the ensuing end game let's
see if we can find a more clever way to
play
I'm going to think about this in silence
for a little while
I have a really interesting idea but I
have to consider it much more carefully
I think there's a couple of tempting
candidate moves I like the look of King
H7
I like the look of King H7 and then Rook
G8 as we discussed
I also really like the look of Queen to
D7
which is a weird looking move but could
be very very good because It prepares
Bishop to G4
I also like Bishop to F6 which is maybe
the least intuitive move of all of them
but it protects the H4 pawn and we could
actually involve the other Rook into the
attack via G7
okay let me decide
to me the tie breaker
is to make the most flexible of all the
moves which in my eyes is King to H7
because this doesn't commit us to any
particular way of playing a very
important you might look at this and say
wait wait a second we're walking into a
pin and why does Knight G5 check no
Knight G5 check is not possible of
course we now need to keep contact with
the G5 Square as long as we don't
protect it with another piece which is
what we're going to do on the next move
unless white poses a threat we're going
to play Bishop to F6 then our Queen is
much more free and we're preparing Rook
G8 and if both of those moves are made
if we play Bishop F6 and then we play
Rook G8 we will be threatening Bishop E6
to G4 which simply traps White's Queen
okay does that make sense
so Bishop F6 Rook G8 and Bishop G4 are
our three next moves unless white poses
us a concrete threat which he does not
King H1 is not a threat I don't see any
reason for us to refrain
from uh the move Bishop F6
what do you think about this yes I think
it's a perfect opportunity to play
Bishop F6 we have to be very very
careful
and hopefully you're able to see what we
have to be careful about I was briefly
considering a sacrifice on F4 like
Knight takes F4 EF and Bishop takes F4
is nothing to sneeze at because it
attacks the H6 Pawn but we can simply
drop our Bishop back to G7 and this is
the importance of playing flexibly
you're able to adapt to the new set of
circumstances because you haven't
committed your pieces to any squares
where they can't go back from
okay Bishop C3
that's another good move but I think our
opponent's defensive strategy is
starting to falter
Okay so
what's important here
is is that we can play Rook G8 anyway
or we can but then white has Bishop
takes pawn and if we play Bishop G4
white takes the bishop I'll show this
after the game and hits Our Queen and
then the White Queen gets an Escape
Route via the fifth rank so can we find
another way of preparing Bishop G4 that
circumvents this problem well yes
there's Queen to D7 which I've
previously mentioned then if Bishop
takes E5 we can play Bishop G4 and I
believe the queen is trapped I don't
think
white has any way of escaping that so
let's go Queen D7
and again hopefully that logic made
sense
were threatening Bishop G4
and Bishop F7 is also a potential
possibility in an emergency because then
the F5 square is going to be protected
by our Queen
I mean it's a it's a move that you
should be okay and our opponent blenders
I mean there was no def the only defense
was Knight H3 back to F2 but then we
would have played Rook G8 and that
position is completely winning because
we're just massacring him down the G
file I don't think there's any long-term
defense there
but our opponent collapses it's like the
Smith approach we we pose 10 threats in
a row and eventually your opponent gets
low on time and they miss one of them
only 23 moves which is crazy to me
it's like yeah uh the game the day
before yesterday which was only like 30
moves or something but it's felt like so
much longer we spent almost all of our
time uh in the middle game
and there's a lot to unpack here this
was great
all right GG lovely game there's a
couple of critical moments that I want
to hit on
after Knight C6 okay first of all first
things first let me quickly recap why
Knight C3
why Knight C3 is such a tricky move so
let's say that you're an accelerated
Dragon player
and you learned from a book that the
best move is D6 well now white can play
Knight F3 and you've gotten what's
called a move ordered using that as a
verb you've got to move ordered into an
open Sicilian that you don't play if
you're a knight or a flare no problem
you play Knight F6 white plays D4 and
you you play the Niner but if you're an
accelerated player then you have a
problem the only way to avoid D4 is to
play the move E5 but it should be
self-evident why this move is bad you're
weakening key squares in the center
what's interesting is that there is a
legitimate line where you play E5 here
but I really don't recommend it to uh
beginner and intermediate players this
this is a legitimate line you'll find a
lot of Grand Master games here but I
think it's very dubious uh positionally
so again the move that you play on move
two depends first and foremost on what
you play against Knight F3 and D4
because we're accelerated Dragon players
we play Knight C6 Knight F3 we respond
with G6 and after D4 we're chilling by
the way if you're a Powell some player
or tomato player you want to go E6 this
is I think a great move against Knight
C3 but again you have to be ready to
face Knight F3 if you're a taimano flare
no problem Knight C6 D4 CD and queen C7
now of course in many cases your
opponent who plays Knight C3 is not an
open Sicilian player so oftentimes you
can get away with playing T6 or E6
you're not gonna get Knight F3 a lot of
the time but I'm trying to make the most
objectively uh
sort of the the most objective opening
recommendations and you have to factor
in uh this type of idea
okay so we play Knight C6 and here white
has a Crossroads there are three three
major moves here one of them is what our
opponent played Bishop to B5 we faced it
once before uh a game that I think I
actually lost
um G3 is called the closed Sicilian this
is an older move that's still very
popular I used to play this with white
and then the third main move is F4 which
is the entry point to the Grand Prix
attack which I think we've also faced
what I'm not going to do is look
carefully at the Grand Prix attack in
the closed Sicilian because there's more
than enough to look at after Bishop B5
now I mentioned that Knight D4 is the
most popular move by far and I
referenced the trumpowski the trumpowski
goes D4 Knight F6 and now Bishop to G5
and you might be aware that the main
move here is Knight F6 to E4 immediately
hitting the bishop of course the Knight
is later chased away from the center but
the way you can think of it is both
sides lose the tempo and those tempos
cancel each other out White's gonna have
to move the bishop and then black will
have to move the Knight super super
complicated opening
named after Octavio trompowski a
Brazilian player
because I know people are thinking
okay so uh Bishop B5 Knight D4 is wildly
theoretical this is a super theoretical
line already at this point white has a
further Crossroads there is the very
dangerous move Knight F3 which is what
we faced previously and I did some
analysis in this position there's the
traditional move which is Bishop C4
generally black plays E6 and then white
tries to smoke out this Knight with the
move the main line here is Knight G2
although Knight F3 is almost as popular
and I think the move that's all of the
rage now
is that is all the rage I think there's
even a move where black goes back to C6
this is yeah this is super popular now
going back to C6 and you might say well
white will play D4 and get an open
Sicilian with an extra Tempo yeah but
this bishop is really stupid on C4 it's
just biting on granite
so I will leave the analysis of this
position to you we might get another
game here and I might play Knights E4
the reality is that I'm not too familiar
uh with this line from Black's
perspective because again as a knight
Earth player myself I play D6 here and
Bishop B5 check in this position is
still a move but it's really not as
dangerous because black and black with
Bishop D7
okay and okay this is a reasonable line
from light's perspective its position is
equal but there's nothing to fear here
all right so let's focus on the move
that we played in the game which is of
course G6 so white correctly plays
Bishop takes E6 and we decided in this
game to take back with uh the b-pawn
our opponent's next move is totally
sensible D3 wifey and keto our Bishop
white plays F4 this is the recommended
way of approaching this position and we
responded with D6 so again why didn't I
play instead the move D5
which actually the engine does prefer uh
D5 to D6 but what worried me about this
move let's say white plays Knight F3
okay here I actually missed a uh a
pretty cool idea that transitions into
an end game who can tell me how black
can force the Queens off the board and
reach an opposite colored Bishop end
game who sees this hidden idea
and this will lead me to a detour that
uh hopefully will enable me to make an
instructive point
yeah Bishop takes C3 check and it's
always hard to convince yourself to give
up your fan counted bishop and for good
reason right normally you don't want to
give up your fiancato Bishop for
anything because it leaves your king
side permanently but there are
exceptions and those exceptions are if
there's a tactic that allows you to win
material and or if there's some way
let's say to get into an end game
because in an end game the role of weak
squares and weaknesses in general is
greatly diminished this position
strikes me as about equal both sides
have very weak and symmetrical Queen
sides I think this is dead equal so in
terms of equalizing I think D5 might be
the better move I will confess that I
missed Bishop C3 but white can also play
E5 immediately
but the thing that happens after white
plays E5 much like in an opening like
the kerokan you can draw a parallel
between this type of structure and a lot
of situations that you get uh in the
French defense or in the gurga nidse
opening which goes E4 G6 this is the
modern
who can tell me let's see who knows what
is the gurga nidsay which move in this
position Hikaru plays this very often
represents the gurgaonidze system named
after a Georgian Grandmaster it's C6
sort of a cross between the Karo Khan
and the modern very good Harry
and if white plays F4 which is the main
line you get virtually an identical uh
situation on the king side and Black's
main idea in the gurganizza is actually
to establish full control of the light
squares on the king side that's why you
often see black playing H5 this prevents
G4 and the move G4 controls this very
important F5 Square so black then often
follows up with Knight H6 and Knight to
F5 and the Karo Khan itself uh in a lot
of lines in the advanced Caro you get
something very similar again you have
this F5 Square
and uh in many situations such as in the
short variation which is considered by
now the main line uh black often plays
Knight D7 and then 97 and the bishop
often drops back and the Knight occupies
its place on F5 so basically black is
playing on the light squares black is
trying to carve out for himself a little
kingdom on the king side using those
light squares
so you can see something similar in the
event that white plays E5 here who can
tell me uh which move is really
consistent with what I just talked about
one of them is H5 but you don't even
need to play H5 you can directly develop
the Knight to H6 and you might say well
but White's Pawn chain is really
annoying that's true but in a situation
like this I really like the move F6
chipping away at White's Pawn chain
But ultimately what worried me about a
position like this is the fact that
these pawns can be very easily targeted
white has this super annoying move
Knight A4 super annoying move Knight A4
and it's actually hard to defend the
pawn on C5 whereas pushing C4 well then
white can play D4 and build up an even
more menacing Pawn chain and also white
has the C5 Square as an outpost
according to the engine in this exact
position black is fine because FeFe and
Knight F7 hits the pawn are actually no
the computer move here is oh Knight G4
go the other way so attack the E5 Pawn
if white defends it then you keep
attacking it with Queen C7 and if white
defends it
again then you keep attacking it again
with Rook F5 that's why you play Knight
G4 rather than Knight F7 so that you
have this additional move Rook F5 and if
white finally takes on C5 black takes
this very important Pawn on E5 and our
pieces start to breathe in fact black is
already winning here
so
it's interesting that blacks play on the
king side and in the center really
counter balances the weakness of uh
of these pawns but I remember a game
that I played years ago and this
influenced my perception where I got
completely outplayed in exactly this
kind of structure I later won that game
with a nice combination but the memory
of this game stuck in my mind as I was
deciding between D5 and D6 here's the
how that game went
uh and hopefully this detour isn't too
extensive I'm just trying to give you
background on you know this option and
the structures that arise as a result
here is that game
so it was a very similar opening
actually very similar it was a Grand
Prix attack technically but it was
virtually the same thing here you can
see that structure
and what ended up happening is I did
play the move D5 my opponent played E5
and this position is horrible for black
because White's Queen is already on H4
and if white has a single more move he's
gonna play Knight A4 and Bishop B3 and
this Pawn on C5 is going to get under
Fire so I kind of Desperately played C4
but that didn't really help I plays DC
and here my opponent did something
really stupid he gave up an exchange
with C takes D5 and then D6 this led to
a completely wild position instead all
white had to do for a huge Advantage was
play the move B3
this forces black to play DC and now
white could bring the Rook to D1 why it
could bring the bishop to A3 and
hopefully you can see how bad uh this
black structure is and the bishop on G7
of course is out of commission as well
so anyways I was influenced by this
particular game while we're on this
topic there was one further detour that
I wanted to make which is to really
emphasize the importance of not
forgetting that giving up your
fianchetto Bishop is a legitimate device
in some positions and it's one of the
easiest moves to miss my coach did an
entire lesson on examples where
one side gives up their fianchetto
Bishop uh in order to achieve something
there was a famous game of whitechashek
against caruano where Fabi gives up his
King's Indian Bishop for positional
reasons but here's a a very famous game
where black gives up well I won't tell
you exactly what happens because I have
already given it away
but take a look at this position in a
game between the young got akomski and
GM Sergey vyakov here in this position
gotta plays the pretty reasonable
looking move Knight to D4 who can spot
the blunder in White's last move the
hidden blunder I should say
Bishop takes D4 okay but what's the
follow-up folks come on
yeah Bishop D4 Bishop takes D4
and now the hidden trick
yeah you play E6 and you chase the
Knight away big deal Knight has to go
back to E3 Knight F4 E5 is a fork but
now after Knight E3 Black Goes E5 and
the bishop is trapped
Bishop has only one square and after
Rook B7 the bishop is lost and kamski
was forced to give that Bishop up and he
ended up losing the game as you can see
so anyways just file that away in your
sort of mental directory of ideas
and so I
can see that it turns out D5 might be a
superior move despite uh the drawbacks
Associated and the dangers associated
with this particular Pawn structure okay
so we decided to play D6 after Knight F3
I really like this idea of playing
Knight H6 one further detour I will
prove to you that I have known this idea
for a long time and the first time that
I tried it was against none other than
Robert Hess in a game where I had a lot
of success with this setup here is the
game against Hess where I first
uh trotted out this uh
this crazy looking idea
I won't show you the whole game super
complicated game
2008 the first time Hess and I faced
each other not the last
uh not the last
so it was a close Sicilian
and my coach had taught me this line and
I figured to hell with it I'm just gonna
go Knight H6 and it's the same exact
idea you're preparing the move F5 then
the Knight drops back to F7 so you can
see the same ingredients the same types
of moves okay here we trade Knights but
later in the game
I played the move E5 again creating the
same Pawn box I got a great position in
the game ended in a draw
so uh exactly the same ideas here with
the move Knight H6 the reason I don't
like Knight F6 is because black could
get checkmated so quickly and I've
already shown examples of this in a
previous speedrun video but just to sort
of reiterate let's say black you know
just kind of Dilly Dally's uh White gets
the queen no big deal let's grab some
space well our after F5 already black is
on the cusp of getting checkmated
because white gets the bishop to H6 the
Knight jumps into G5 and all that stands
between black and Checkmate is this
measly Knight on F6 and there are so
many cool tactics that are associated
with getting this Knight out of the
picture for example if you consider a
position like this whatever let's make a
random move for black white has a
beautiful tactical idea that's actually
very typical in Grand Prix attack
structures I'll let you guys try to find
it white to play and it's Force
checkmate
you know what the goal is the goal is to
deflect the Knight on F6 but it's easier
said than done because the D5 square is
controlled you play the move E5
black takes and you vacate the E4 Square
for the night
black has to take with a pawn and now
the Rook opens up and Rook takes F6
leads to Checkmate because now H7 cannot
be protected so something to remember
ways to deflect the F6 Knight this is
classic across many openings so in a
nutshell this is why I wanted to play
Knight H6 and F5 to prevent white from
himself playing the move F5 uh before
it's too late
okay so we need to uh we'll skip over
castles and I already think that after
Knight F7 Black's position is very
decent looking at the engine it does
give equality here so it's not like
white is objectively all that much
better maybe a tiny Edge what I kept
dancing around during the game was the
reason why E5 is bad now that the game
is over who can tell me why uh E5 is a
mistake and it's not as hard as I made
it out to be but it's just unexpected
black to play and win upon
it's not rookie a rookie a doesn't
really do anything because it puts the
Rook on a closed file yeah so it's D
takes E5 F takes E5 Knight takes E5
and then Queen D4 check picks up the
Knight and results in an extra Pawn
Bishop B3 Queen E5 and that's it black
is up upon how do you find something
like this well it has to do with the
fact that white has played out for so
this diagonal is weakened so you're
always looking for ways to exploit that
diagonal to your advantage okay
so our opponent withstood the Temptation
and played Bishop d8 we throw in the
move Rook B8 B3 is fine and we create
the pawn box with the move E5 and
hopefully the rationale behind this move
now makes a certain degree of sense F
takes E5
we take back with a knight and I think
Rook a E1 was actually a very serious
mistake I think allowing the move F4 is
the beginning of the end for white
because now white is devoid of any
active counter play whereas we have a
very clear plan of attacking on the king
side as counter-intuitive as it may
appear I think white should have kept
the center open with e takes F5 we would
have recaptured with the bishop and
according to the engine white just
collects his pieces in the center with
Rook a to E1 black plays a move such as
Queen D7 you know to connect the Rooks
and prepare rookie eight white plays
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes Knight
and a move like Knight to E4
centralizing the Knight and the position
is super complicated I would take black
but it is equal according to the engine
which gives Bishop H6 now it gives
Bishop D4 check King H2
and there's a lot of repetitions here
like Bishop E5 King G1 is a draw of
course we can play Rook F7
but now white plays a nonchalant move
like King H1 and the game continues it's
complicated the problem that Black Faces
in a position like this is that the
Knight on e4 is very difficult to chase
away because D5 always runs into Knight
takes C5 so as as impressive as Black's
Bishops look it's hard to actually make
progress and this move is very tempting
but it loses because after Rook takes F7
you have to take back with the King and
that walks into Knight G5 check picking
up the bishop so
I really think that our opponents
biggest chance to to keep the position
balanced would have been to not allow us
to push the pawn down to F4 hopefully
everybody now understands why F4 is so
strong
so F4 and I already think that white is
like borderline lost from a practical
standpoint our opponent drops the Knight
back we start assembling our attacking
forces G5 and really the most
interesting moment occurred I think
after H6 Knight takes C5 checking the
engine
as I hinted at Bishop takes E5 is
preferred by the computer and the
computer almost always uh weighs the
positional considerations highly peace
placement and square control that the
new stockfish really appreciates the
value of those things which is what
makes chess computers now so much
stronger than they used to be right they
used to greatly underestimate the value
of certain positional considerations
the reason I didn't take with the bishop
again is because I felt like closing
down the center helps us focus our
attention more directly on playing H5
and G4 I also was a little bit annoyed
by the prospect of Knight G4 but now
that I look at it
we can just drop our Bishop back I was
worried about the movie five I was
worried that white would open up the
center and create problems but again
here we just have Bishop takes Knight
which for some reason I missed Queen
takes bishop and we can just grab the
Free Pawn with Bishop takes E5 there's
one innocuous check and we just lift our
King up to H7 the bishop is a hero and
notice how the pawn on C5 is protecting
against the possibility of D4 white has
some exchange sack but it doesn't do
anything we just take back
and here we can just trade Queens with
Queen D4 check so definitely the best
move objectively was Bishop E5 we played
de
so according to the engine and this is
so interesting because our opponent
he initiated a campaign of trying to
prevent our King Side Pawn storm as you
could see it was a losing battle and it
was a losing battle because white is no
light squares right yeah white can use
the queen as a stop Gap but we're going
to chase the queen out eventually white
can't do anything about that instead the
only way I think for white so muddy the
waters would have been to go directly
for blacks only Achilles heel which are
the queen side Pawns
who can tell me a way that white can
attack the C5 Pawn as efficiently as
possible what's the fastest way the
fastest maneuver in terms of attacking
C5
well it's not C3 that doesn't do
anything it's not A4 that doesn't do
anything it's Bishop to C1
this is the computer mode the type of
computer and I still think the engine is
underestimating black splay at a lower
depth I think black is much better here
and if Queen E8 white immediately sends
the bishop to A3
anyway so I remember I was talking about
this during the game what happens if
black just ignores everything that white
is doing well it's good in principle the
problem is you start losing a ton of
crap you lose the pawn on C5 you don't
want to give away this Rook you have to
move it I like to move and the problem
isn't isn't the black loses material
it's what that C5 Pawn was doing what
was it doing well it was controlling
along with the E5 Pawn the D4 Square
you know that the best way to deflect
your opponent's attention from Attack on
the side of the board is to strike in
the center when the Center opens the
situation destabilizes when it
stabilizes it's harder to focus in a
single-minded fashion on an attack so
white plays the move d4 yes and if black
just stubbornly continues with Queen G6
we're going to run out of pieces pretty
soon
so for example consider this position
already you can't play G4 because you
drop another Pawn
so by opening the center white is able
to take Black's attention away
and you might say well no problem let's
just defend the pawn with Queen E7 and
maybe this is what black should do but
now it's harder to play H5
so according to the engine in this
position black keeps a big Advantage by
playing very calmly Bishop E6 Bishop A3
and indeed the move Queen E7 the problem
is that white has no way to accentuate
the attack on the C5 Pawn perhaps white
can move the Knight away and try to put
a queen on F2 but already here there's
the move G4 even without H5
and after H takes G4 Queen H4 black
develops a furious attack because Bishop
takes G4 is next Bishop takes C5 just
Rook F7 and it's like minus two if white
plays back to F2 you can play F3
or you can play H5 sacking another pawn
and just Bishop fa this is a cool line
black just brings all of the pieces to
the king side F3 is Unstoppable and
White's King is gonna get massacred also
Rook H7 takes H5 is very strong
but still I think it's clear that this
was black White's only chance to go
after the C5 pawn and in return notice
the two ways of flying yes you can close
your eyes and attack but don't hesitate
to make these patient Moves In order to
eliminate your opponent's counter play
this is what queen E7 does by the way C3
doesn't actually threaten anything and
black could even prepare H5 with King H7
King G6 the engine suggests day 5
preventing B4
D4 is not possible because black can
take with the bishop at the end
so
anyways I don't want to beat a dead
horse Queen H5
our opponent is really the continuation
of the end and again important not to
fear ghosts Knight G4 don't go Bishop F7
because if Knight takes H6 you've got to
calculate you go King H7 and then Bishop
F7 traps the queen much like we did in
the game
uh so H4 we play simply G takes H4
flexibility that is the name of the game
in this game opening up the G5 Square
for black screen this type of position
is completely lost for white because G4
is Unstoppable and what I want you to
understand is that even in the end game
these Pawn storms are are wildly
dangerous let alone the fact that black
is up a pawn and everything is
unassailable
like white just can't stop this from
happening
and once F3 happens I mean it's very
obvious why black is winning here you
just have connected passers yeah G3 also
is completely winning
so anyways
that is the key observation G takes H4
it snags an extra Pawn yes but it opens
up the G5 Square for the queen and as I
mentioned during the game if white tries
to keep the Queens on the board then we
attack by grabbing the G file with our
King H7 Rogue G8 and if white tries to
do the same well we move the bishop out
of the way white is out of moves and we
can just triple on the G file you can
improve your position and improve your
position and eventually something is
going to give something's going to give
here the engine suggests a very
interesting idea it suggests the idea of
moving the queen away from the G file so
that the Rook could take its place
that's why leading with the queen is
often a bad idea we bring our Queen back
to F7 and white is not uh simply cannot
stop Rook G3 which chases the queen away
now the queen comes back in and G2 is
hanging notice the difference right here
the Rook is leading so Rook takes G2 is
a threat here the queen is leading so
this is not possible because at the end
of the day White's going to give his
Queen up and emerge upper Rook now how
do I know that I have enough time for
all of this well why does that a counter
play why does no ideas and okay if white
tries to go after the C5 Pawn here
that's like pinching a dinosaur that
does not matter at all it doesn't matter
anymore because black has assembled all
of his pieces on the king side here
Bishop E7 is very strong
moving the queen away congrats you
played D4 it doesn't help anymore
because Rook G3 is still decisive
and it's still the same the same drill
okay so when is the supporting actress
says yes sir likes to say
in any case our opponent played Knight
H3 we played King H7 just the general
improving move King H1 Bishop F6 our
strategy is to play Rook G8 and Bishop
G4 the last chance for white I think was
in fact to sacrifice a piece and I will
admit to one embarrassing oversight I
forgot that after Bishop takes F4 The
Rook in the corner is hanging on B8 that
would have changed my strategy I
thinking H7 is an inaccuracy not a
mistake it would have been better to
make a move like Queen E7
what I forgot about
is that the Rook is hanging now black is
still much better after Bishop G5
because you have two pieces for a rook
and not just to any any two pieces two
very powerful Bishops so it's minus 1.5
here but according to the engine black
could have kept a much bigger advantage
uh with the move
Queen to E7
and let's okay now Knight takes F4 is
not dangerous because H6 is not hanging
in the end and if white plays Bishop C3
now you can play a move like Bishop to
D7 to defend the E5 Pawn white is out of
ideas and now you can continue
assembling uh the pieces like we did in
the game with Bishop F6 and Rook G8 so a
little bit more prophylaxis would have
gone a really long way toward uh
preventing all of White's ideas another
theme of this game which is that when
you're not in a hurry it's such a good
idea to remove all of your opponent's
ideas because then it'll be so easy for
you to attack because your opponent
basically just has to sit around and
wait which is what happened in this game
so I got a little bit lucky that
uh that our opponent didn't spot Knight
takes up for and after Queen D7 the game
is over technically Queen F3 or Knight
F2 would have staved off defeat but
after Rook G8 hopefully you can already
see how decisive the attack down the G
files if white plays Bishop takes E5 we
have a lot of winning moves but Queen to
G7 is a really elegant move because it
hits G2 with mate and it hits the bishop
we just win the bishop we win the game
probably white has to move the queen
away and now I think the game just ends
after Rook G3 and Rook G8 and H3 is
gonna tear white apart
or queen G7 much like we discussed in
the game
so the critical moment in this entire
game and our opponent of course blunters
the queen here there's nothing to talk
about was I think G takes H4 because I
think a lot of people here would be
inclined to keep the pawn on G5 and that
could have seriously damaged our
attacking chances so if we played a move
like Queen E7 the eval bar actually goes
way up because white establishes a
blockade on the light squares and it's
not easy all of a sudden to deal with
White's pieces right if we go Queen D7
there's a nasty little check on H6
suddenly Lex pawns which aren't dark
squares and are attackable by the bishop
become very weak
so this ability to change your Paradigm
of attack from one idea to another is
really important at higher levels we
started by in by intending to play H5
and G4 but once White made an unusual
move we adapted to the circumstances we
took the pawn not trying to make too big
of a deal of this move perhaps it's
obvious to you but nonetheless I think
it's an important skill uh that is
behind a lot of successful attacks being
able to adapt given what your opponent
the defensive strategy that your
opponent is adopting and and of course
the elimination of counter play and not
overestimating Pawn structure another
hidden theme of this game our Pawn
structure was terrible the entire game I
did could not possibly care less about
the queen side because the puns were
doing their job these two pawns had one
job it was to prevent white from opening
the center and they did that job
amazingly and that is why white White's
only chance would have been to attack
the only weakness in Black's position
the C5 Pawn
so there's I could talk about this game
for like an hour there's a lot more to
discuss but I think this is a good time
for us to pause I don't want to overdo
it you know I don't want to overload
each analysis with too many themes I
think this is enough and remember that
you can always analyze the game on your
own you can always dig deep into the
opening if that's what you want to do or
if you have questions that were
unanswered you can analyze with the
engine and that is how you learn and on
that note guys I will end I will uh
board Nick is waiting for me actually to
do the the course so that's what I'm
going to be doing
and uh that means it's time for me to
call it a day
yeah cool three and a half hours I think
that's enough for today so happy Friday
everybody hope you enjoyed the game uh
this will be up on YouTube as usual
and I will definitely stream tomorrow
probably first half of the day actually
because I'm busy in the evening
but uh I hope you enjoyed the Blitz and
The Vibes in the game
one more time of course I have a YouTube
channel every sub counts
so thanks to everybody who supports and
uh
have a great rest of your Friday
everybody uh thanks for hanging out I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]